you came over from Dexter they kill
folks we kill em dead folks yes what are
you planning on killing more folks well
you wanted a dog before I got the
Chester's million body count was pretty
high ya know there's a lot of people
missing and there are guessing from the
first two seasons but yeah this is in a
way the storytelling is very much like
Dexter this season it's a little bit
more serialized and it's not quite so
standalone and you know we threw a lot
of stuff that you guys in the first two
hours that's all going to play out over
this entire season not just over an
episode but the entire season and I can
assure all of you that we meant what we
said we are answering all the questions
maybe not in the time frame that you
want but by the end of this season you
will know everything and you're starting
to see that you know the very first
clues of that mark if I can just quickly
hold my character Barbie who the hell
are you are you good are you bad explain
Kristen I'm complex yeah you are
essentially I have an agenda for
Chester's Mill and I have a plan that I
you know put into motion and I'm trying
to get the whole community behind
because I feel that it's the best thing
for us to survive because things are
getting desperate I'm running out of
supplies etc and so I can I refer to
this as a kinship a collective
and some people go along and some don't
hey Mike a couple things I want to ask
you but I want to start with the love
triangle yes sir
how is it going how's it playing in a
love triangle it's a terrible problem to
have it's yeah it's I said to Tim
earlier on the season I really love
triangle tough because you see and it's
made even more difficult by the the
constructs of our show which are
everyone who's in here is in here so how
would he get more people in here to
evolve in a love triangle that we
haven't seen is it just gonna be hokey
the way that they orchestrated the time
that we spend in the the matrix and the
alternate reality doing that I think
it's set up a believable premise as to
how Mark's character probably well
Mary's character found their way into
the dome and that Barbie and Ava kylus
Kylie's character have lived in their
minds they lived a year Joey and I have
been together for a little over three
weeks so you can see how that might
complicate things must be crazy when you
get the scripts whoa whoa whoa it's fun
they're too beautiful wonderfully
talented women and they only
once in a while so I can't ask for much
more and we gave you Barbies ass this
season so you might have missed it small
hey Kahn want to ask you about being in
the cocoon and getting out of the cocoon
getting what was that getting out of the
cocoon what was that how did that go
when you shot the scene it was cold man
it was cold but uh no I mean it was
definitely really cool I know I know
mike has a crazy story
let me explain everybody traffic hakuna
you escaped right but you didn't really
escape easily no it was it's difficult
and you know we came out of we came out
of the cocoons very confused kind of you
know not really one like really not
really knowing why we were there and
what was going on and then you know in
turn kind of realizing what happened
while we were in the cocoons was was a
big deal for us and I don't know I think
it's really crazy by the way if you want
to recreate that at home for yourselves
all you need is some KY jelly and some
corn syrup so that's what I was gonna
ask you what is that goop really and
might tell your story about getting out
of the cocoon oh I had to forcibly make
an exit we were also pumping dry ice
into into you know the floor level and
as I looked down as I'm standing in this
cocoon which takes 15 minutes to reset
I see the dry ice level kind of coming
up and one second I was breathing the
next second I went to take a breath and
there was no oxygen left because it
displaces the oxygen and I literally had
to go into a bunch of left hooks and
roundhouse punches and punch my way out
of this thing just so I could just like
a breathe and I ruined a cocoon doing it
so and it was our bad because we almost
broke the one you're kind of cardinal
rule of television production which is
don't kill your actors
I think it was I think it was a veiled
threat that was being sent man well we
know your method yeah yeah why not love
to get into it mike has never forgotten
a line since that day it was to just let
you know bar because it goes I think
they were being serious about that
though no mark I heard that originally
your character
they had a nickname of margul because
they were hoping to get you but they
weren't sure they could get you so they
nicknamed the character Margaux was that
true that is true Tim and Neil who
couldn't be here today they yes they had
me in mind when they were conceived this
character which is so flattering to hear
for an actor and yeah then they pitched
this to me and over the phone and it was
mystifying and I mean the reality was
you know we just kept thinking she's
never gonna want to do this you know
this is this is really some crazy out
there stuff but why not why not make
that phone call so right before the
phone call started I look to needle our
showrunner and just said yeah she's
either gonna you know to hang up on us
and tell us what crazy or you know
hopefully she'll want to do it and and
not hang up on us and she didn't and we
just got incredibly lucky but but not
lucky in a sense of you know what she
brings to this role into his character
those were the things that we were
looking for whether it was you know mark
specifically we needed a great actress
and we got a great actress
it's been a ball really look forward to
the evolution of and these guys aren't
bad I mean I'm not saying the marks the
best
yes marks numbers Neil Barrett couldn't
be here exactly one of the executive
producers he is sick but I remember
talking the producers before the first
season and they said what we have about
five years laid out but then when you
come in now and you kind of mess with
that plan how did you mess with that
point well indeed you know I always kind
of refer to this creative process of
putting up your Christmas tree you know
that's what we the writers do we put up
a tree and we want to make sure we know
what kind of tree we want and it's you
know kind of upright and steady and then
you start putting the ornaments on but
if you put your ornaments on person you
have a really shitty tree it's not gonna
look so great so I came into the show
this season so they've been on the other
two two seasons and I kind of found all
these Christmas presents under the tree
already that I got to start to to open
up and how I approached coming into a
show that had already been up and
running was a lot of these questions
that we're answering our questions that
I wanted to answer because I was
watching the show and and I wanted to
know just what is up with the
butterflies you know the egg in the dome
and so you know when we sat down with
the other writers and we just started
you know kind of putting all of this
together some of it did fit into this
master plan and then other things we we
took some left-hand turns but it's all
going to tie together it's all going to
make sense in a macro sense for the
series this season is paying off things
that you saw in seasons 1 and 2 Colin
would ask you about Joe we watched you
kind of grow up a little bit on this
show
well he continued to evolve this season
I think I think some of Joe's best
growth is in this third season I think
if we kind of look back at season two
you know the with the losing of you know
Angie and all the other things that
happened I think Joe always looked up to
to Barbie as a hero and it's kind of
like a mentor and I think he'll continue
to do that but I think also in this
third season he he really finds himself
and he really grows up you know he has a
little bit of a love triangle himself
with Hunter and nori so we'll see how
that plays out and see how he handles
that but I think Joe is a lot more
courageous than this season and it has a
lot more to offer under the dome
he's also physically growing there right
well you got to put people on boxes to
make it believable this is only been
three weeks love triangles everywhere
that's right the experience been like
going down to Wilmington joining this
cast you're a veteran of so many great
shows and what has it been like working
with this crew
I've been wonderful everyone was very
good welcoming towards me and I've been
in Wilmington before 20 some years ago
and it's grown quite a bit and it's a
charming community and it's right on the
water and probably about all the shark
attacks but but everybody here the
writing staff everybody's being super
cool and fun yeah it's been a blast yeah
every season you lose people does that
make it nervous every time you open the
script because some clearly someone's
going to go this season
100% I actually the next one we're
shooting now I've revealed anything but
I couldn't believe what I do at the end
of this episode and I almost like just
started crying upon reading that
they take they take a little bit of joy
in breaking the news what was that
process like when they break it how to
keep them on their best behavior you get
your car wash you know those little
things and and you know I think
sometimes a series you know can can have
depths that don't really mean anything
and and I think this season these deaths
because you've come to know these
characters so well they're really gonna
matter because it's all gonna start to
build really with tonight's episode and
moving forward they you know I usually
don't use this kind of language but
things are gonna get bananas like mark
you and Dina trapped in a bird cage for
a while what tell us about that
experience yes we have all of our things
all like four or five of them I can't
recall now but they were all inside of
the large bird cage and we essentially
have a philosophical discussion about
man humanity you know any kind of life
force out there and the differences
between the two and which is more
important and more lasting and it was it
was really fun working with him and and
we had this you know cage between us and
my kids you have to watch what it all
entails a Big Jim has really met his
match and the thing that makes them such
a foe for Christine is he's a narcissist
he's this self-centered I come first
before anybody else and if you are
coming from a collective the kinship
kind of point of view that is no pun
intended that is really alien to you
that how could anyone be that
self-centered and yet you're gonna need
that to survive and that's something
that Julia is going to start to
understand and get a kind of new
appreciation of Big Jim the season how
was the cast welcome to all the new
folks Mike oh ask you in college the new
folks have come in
yes they've obviously survived and now
it's a it's a it's always great having
people come in and sometimes they come
in and stay and sometimes they don't but
it's a we've been really fortunate to
have a lot of great eggs over the last
couple years walk through the door and
and it's always been painful watching
them go because filmmaking is weird that
way you take six months and you jump
into this pit and your life revolves
around these people constantly and so
everything happens faster relationships
happen faster your friendships form
memory and then all of a sudden it's
like break this was just the life we
were all living so it's tough when
someone has to leave it's fun when
someone else comes in and like I said
we're just really blessed I've had some
really good ones come through and some
really fantastic ones come in now can
you give us I'm sorry oh these
relationships you become very close very
quickly and you have to do any kind of
love scene Oh day two and then you know
the scene in no big deal you know like
you'd never do that oh yes I would
common common no I mean I would just say
you know yeah next question that to that
dude I like you know I really really
enjoy when we get the new cast members
because being one of the younger cast
members on the show I find it a chance
to like learn from you and Kylie bug
great as well and whoever else we may be
having on a particular episode but I
just find it
it's really cool to meet different
actors and actresses and and get to know
them and become friends and and and then
learn what have you learned
I know I know how to play good I know
how to play good villain now okay watch
out when you sit next to the season from
she's done a few of these panels Tim can
we give for each character just a little
direction of where they're headed well
they may not know humanity may very well
rest on this one this one oh man she's
just getting warmed up with the kind of
stuff that she's she's got coming and
for Barbie you know he might want to
start thinking about shopping at Toys R
Us
for multiple toys are just kids it's an
alien life force you never know having a
be a little boys they need you know you
know what looking at Barbies character
and his evolution and the women in his
life
be careful my dog I know I got a Juris
road here I'm sorry careful Mike
Rochelle and I have have really formed a
wonderful bond that over the three years
that we've done this and that you can
you can trust in in almost every
circumstance and every scene to show up
give a hundred percent and it is
respectful of of boundaries and
everything else
beautiful dancer doing right now they
all have a special place in my heart but
yeah but Rochelle and I I think I'm
special special little special actory
bond factory factory bond hey Tim what
is it do you feel that what is the
reason that people are so attached to
this show and Chester's building you
know I think it just gets back to just
genre kinds of shows the thing that
attracts me just as an audience member
not as a writer you know it's so much
are the shows that ask the big questions
like what if and to me that's the
potential of telling a story under a
dome it's such an amazing big you know
concept and premise to explore and
haven't haven't
that done before and and so you get to
tell maybe familiar themes in the
stories but I think this one resonates
because when you get a group of people
together and you certainly see it in
reality TP it does sometimes bring out
the best in people and brings out the
worst in people I think you can identify
with those members on a reality show I
think you can identify with these
members these characters on a show like
like under the dome you can relate to
these people who are in a horrible
terrible situation and so that's that's
something that's incumbent upon us as
writers this is to find those things
that you the audience can relate to and
would you do the same thing in that
situation and it's really something I
learned on Dexter you know we made a
serial killer someone you want to root
for so that that takes some doing and
and I think you know that's why the show
resonated and the good shows really do
and I think that's why this is one of
those good shows is you've got these
incredible characters that you're gonna
see different aspects aspects to
especially this season so everything you
saw in the matrix
it didn't matter it wasn't just
make-believe we're gonna see the
repercussions of all of it by the way I
hear the cheers from the texture fans
out there the band's own people love
that show oh yeah I got a line hey see
who's on that one
mark and why is the whole cast but I
know you guys have been here but what
makes it special to be here at comic-con
besides just being able to interact with
the fans so many things I mean first off
the city of San Diego
the hostess all these years in the
kitchen I mean the weather does not suck
okay the weather's pretty doggone good
in almost perfect honestly and but it's
just a beautiful city incredibly
beautiful and so welcoming and the group
of people that attend this from all over
the world
I mean god bless all of you I mean if
some of you have come from I don't know
how far away and your your support and
your you know love and that you have for
every show that you're here for is
something that means a great deal to all
of us and I hope you all can feel that
we have the great deal of weird love and
respect for all of you
mark it since you've investigated a few
crime scenes in your career
how should we go about unraveling your
character I should go about unraveling
your character well it's the character I
played on CSI Catherine willows hope she
have to do with this I think she would
probably take one look at her in size
her up and get her number immediately
and yeah and it would probably be just
to put her in her state is some keep her
there throw away the key block Berna
cage with Dean tomorrow would Catherine
have caught Dexter of course
no you will not let that happen like
your comic-con experience did you've
been here you've been here a few times
how is this for you and what's special
about being here well for us it's a it's
a great shot in the arm because you know
we're over in Bloomington for months and
months and months filming and the show
starts airing it's the beauty of where
we are and North Carolina is that it's a
it's a great small town morello key so
you don't ever get to feel the energy
and the just that that that palpable
energy that's coming for people for a
show and for the work that you're doing
because we're putting a ton of work into
it they're putting a ton of work into it
and to come here this is kind of the
epicenter where everyone lets it all
hang out and it just kind of fills our
cup again to see all y'all's enthusiasm
and excitement and it lets us go oh yeah
right that's why we're doing it just so
everybody knows really literally being
in Wilmington they are in their own
little world they're under their own
little dome the actors are and so it's a
special kind of place to do and film
stuff because you are away from the Oh
Hollywood huh and then you come out into
the world you emerge into the world like
whoa whoa a lot happens in six months
boom it hits you Kyle I'm gonna let you
because I just got the one more question
wrap this thing up but I'm gonna I'm
gonna let you wrap it up how would you
wrap up the under the dome experience
and what this show has met
for you but for your for the cast
members who have survived for those of
you who made it this easy three how
would I wrap it up how would you wrap up
what this experience has been like well
I think the experience overall has been
incredible for me especially like you
know you said earlier I I've kind of
grown up on the show
I mean I've and and like I said whenever
we get new cast members I feel like I'm
constantly watching and learning and
trying to better myself as an actor and
and also you know we have writers who
come hang out on set who make sure that
we're not messing up our lines and
whatnot but it's really cool to get to
talk to them about you know what's
either coming up in the next episode or
or just figuring out a way to better my
craft
I feel like under the dome has been a
really really helpful thing really
helpful I don't want to say job is a
feel like a job but it's been a really
helpful job for me in order to figure
out myself and you know figure out my
career and everything and I think that
we're all kind of doing that as well all
right Tim Colin mark and Mike thanks for
being here today
under the dome you can check it out
tonight tonight's episode dude it will
be a lot of fun all right guys thank you
Thank You heaven Oh fun we do one thing
before we go can we take a picture with
everybody yeah stand up or lean in or
squish together everybody
you